في هذه الانتخابات تغير الكثيره واتم
الابتعاد عن المالوف جورجيا كانت في
الماضي ولايه حمراء تصوت للحزب الجمهوري
بدات تغير هذه الصوره النمطيه في هذه
الانتخابات طبعا الانتخابات الرئاسيه
الماضيه بعد ان صوتت للديمقراطيين اعاده
التاكيد على ذلك في انتخابات مجلس الشيوخ
هذا العام وفي فلوريدا غيرت ابرز
مقاطعاتها الولايه وهي مئه مديد ولاءها من
الحزب الديمقراطي الى الحزب الجمهوري
حينما صوتت لراندي سانتوس على منصب الحاكم
رونتي سانتوس هو اول جمهوري يفوز بهذه
المنطقه منذ 20 عاما ينظر له على انه
القائد الجديد للحزب الجمهوري والذي
سينافس ترامب على بطاقه الترشح للانتخابات
الرئاسيه عام 2024 ايضا نيويورك
كثيره من مقاطعاتها انماط التصويت من
الديمقراطيين الى الجمهوريين
في مجلس النواب
[موسيقى]